[Musique]
faire sortir la bande dessinée des
planches
ça c'est un défi que je me suis lancé
d'abord de manière inconsciente mais
ensuite de manière de plus en plus
consciente
au fil des années un défi que je me suis
pas lancé seul évidemment j'ai fait ça
avec plein collègues et d'amis plein
collaborateurs c'est un défi qu'on a
mené au fil d'une cinquantaine de
projets des petits des moyens et pour
nous faire sortir la bande dessinée
planches et ben essentielle ment ça a
été de la mettre en relation les mettre
en relation avec l'un discipline sur
scène avec le conte avec le théâtre avec
l'improvisation avec le cirque avec la
danse avec la vulgarisation scientifique
ça a été aussi de créer des dialogues à
travers les technologies à travers le
numérique on pour nous tes soeurs fait
ressortir la bande dessinée des planches
dans un cadre performatif qui il faut le
dire est pas étranger au milieu de la
bande dessinée je sais pas si vous
fréquentez beaucoup les événements bd
mais si c'est le cas vous le savez
autant que moi
le dessin en direct il est omniprésent
dans ce type d'événement là ici comme
ailleurs il ya quelque chose chez les
amateurs de bandes dessinées qui fait
qu'on aime vraiment est viscéralement
voir des dessinateurs à l'oeuvre voir la
manières par lesquelles quelqu'un va
attaquer les planches attaqué la page
et ça fait que d'un événement à l'autre
bien on met justement c'est cette
capacité de l'avant et hier certains
événements certains festivals en france
entre hooker angoulême bordeaux c'est
mal aux lions qui s aid d'exploser les
façons par lesquelles on propose du
death en direct au québec on essayait de
faire un peu comme ça aussi
parallèlement ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que la bande dessinée c'est aussi un
terrain d'expérimentation extrêmement
stimulant les auteurs définissent les
règles
évidemment de ce média bloc est en
pleine explosion depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années et les auteurs explose
les règles qu'ils ont eux mêmes
contribué à bâtir eu des grands éditeurs
des petits éditeurs au québec comme
ailleurs qui donne donc des terrains
d'expérimentation pour permettre aux
auteurs de s'amuser de s'éclater de
réinventer constamment la bande dessinée
avant d'aller trop loin on voit ainsi
lexique parce que je parle à exemple du
monde plonge depuis tantôt ben clanche
c'est ça c'est la page en bd donc on
leur livre la plage c'est la planche sur
la planche vous avez une multitude de
petits carrés ceci la case donc dans les
cases on va faire du dessin du texte si
on en a besoin et l'objectif c'est que
d'une case à l'autre on va raconter une
histoire en séquences donc le nar
séquentiel la bande dessinée je ferme ma
petite parenthèse alors on revient au
point de départ
faire sortir la bd des planches c'est
venu au départ d'un coup de fil inopinée
du directeur général du festival québec
bedimo louis côté ils m'appellent un
beau jour il me dit raymond j'aimerais
ça faire un tournoi d'impro bd dans la
prochaine édition du festival est ce que
ça tenterait de le monter avec moi j'ai
dit oui j'ai respiré quelques instants
après ça je le regardais j'ai demandé
oui mais c'est quoi les pro b d et
exhibe un j'ai vu ça en france en boulet
montrant des des dessinateurs on prend
des improvisateurs on prend des
musiciens en limant sans mon improvise
fait qu'on ait pris des dessinateurs on
appris des musiciens on appris des
improvisateurs on les a mis ensemble et
on s'est doté de la ligue québécoise
d'un pro b dès lundi qu' bd évidemment
il fallu définir un peu notre cadre
alors ce qu'on s'est dit aussi qu'on va
placer tout le monde sur scène
donc d'un côté les dessinateurs de
l'autre les musiciens au milieu les
improvisateurs on s'est dit qu'on avait
déjà des éléments techniques pour
permettre aux dessins d'être mise en
performance donc les outils du dessin en
direct alors on a placé une table on a
mis une feuille sur la table et au
dessus de la feuille une caméra donc la
caméra vieille capitale dessin capter le
trait du dessinateur et on retransmet un
peu comme ici aujourd'hui à l'écran
derrière nous donc ce qui fait que vous
public pouvait voir le dessin est ce qui
fait que les improvisateurs peuvent
interagir avec le dessin alors pour nous
la vie qui bd est devenu un formidable
laboratoire
on s'est amusé et on a développé des
contraintes on a éclaté les contraintes
qu'on donnait un peu comme avec le
médium
on a demandé au dessinateur de prendre
le livre si vous me permettez
d'anglicismes est proposé d'aider car
des casses ont
demandez aux joueurs de faire la même
chose d'imposé des styles d'imposer des
personnages les musiciens pourquoi pas
de nous inspirer des bandes dessinées de
nous inspirer des histoires alors les
liquides bd l'improvisation était un
laboratoire extraordinaire mais venus
aussi une petite frustration avec ce
laboratoire sadi dans l'improvisation
c'est de l'instantané évidemment j'y
apprends rien personne c'est plus rapide
de penser et dire ou faire quelque chose
que de penser et de le dessiner
alors il y avait toujours un enjeu de
vitesse est question de solutionner cet
enjeu là on s'est dit qu'on aurait
peut-être besoin d'un laboratoire qui
nous donnerait plus de durer alors on ne
crée parenthèse 9 dont le mandat était
justement fait ressortir la vie des des
planches
j'ai de la suite dans les idées alors
avec tarentaise de fondement ni de
multiples projets est en tout cas c'est
possible en 2015 où on est un enjeu qui
est extrêmement intéressant parce
qu'habituellement si on fait collaborer
un auteur avec un dessinateur et ben les
deux ont conscience de l'existence de
l'autre donc ce qui fait que les deux
vont se laisser de la place dans le
caucase est possible et c'est un mandat
qui nous a été donnée d'illustrer des
textes d'auteurs reconnus de yann martel
margaret atwood russell banks dany
laferrière des textes qui n'ont jamais
été pensé pour le dessin et qui entre
vous et moi n'ont pas vraiment besoin du
dessin non plus pour exister
alors il fallut trouver comment les
illustrer ces textes est ce que dans un
contexte où on parle de folie on y va
avec un dessin axe très chaotique
est ce qu'on essaie de représenter la
pression que subit un personnage par une
foule qui l'observent est ce qu'on est
capable d'amener le spectateur vers
haïti
dans un texte dany laferrière par les
couleurs par le décor
le meilleur exemple de tout sauf si un
tel 06 bein ce qu'on a eu à illustrer un
extrait d' american darling absolument
superbe où la narratrice vient d'être
témoin d'un coup d'état raté il décrit
avec verve toute l'horreur qu'elle vu la
violence la guerre les cris la fumée les
fusils les visages il y avait
littéralement plus rien à dessiner ou
presque c'est la traitant en scène
vincent champoux qui a vu l'éclair et
qui le dit mais ce qui manque c'est le
regard de celle qui observe c'est le
regard de la narratrice
alors on a été versée piste-là qu'on
perçoive l'horreur dans ses yeux et que
peut-être on crée une communion une
communication entre on espérait
l'horreur dans le regard de ceux qui
écoutaient et regardez notre mise en
lecture dessinée ça nous a pris une
grande leçon ce projet là c'est l'idée
de dépasser de gadgets
si on dessine si on intègre le dessin
simplement pour l'intégrer parce que
c'est ça notre mandat c'est ça notre
objectif est bien on rate complètement
notre coup il faut avoir une raison pour
le faire
une justification tangible réelle
concrète
parallèlement phil dowd projet on a
développé ont exploré des outils
rencontre avec le ciel dessinés on le
fait pendant deux trois ans et ça me
paraissent extrêmement stimulant parce
qu'au niveau du dessin on a quand même
une panoplie d'outils on a le feu
évidemment on ne le pastel le fusain
l'aquarelle on ne le papier et
l'informatique avec le cirque ont eu
tout autant d'outils le hula-hoop le
bâton contact elle les acrobaties ecce
terra la jonglerie alors de mettre en
commun ses outils là et de voir comment
ils pouvaient coexister
ça nous paraissait assez extraordinaire
alors on a commencé à le faire on
s'amusait par exemple avec un diabolo
diabolo c'est comme une espèce de tout
piqué sur une corde qu'on peut faire
rebondir et ben nous on s'amuse à faire
les traits et le diabolo dans son
mouvement devait imiter le trait du
dessinateur
on ne prie le cube qui est une immense
boîte il y perd lourdes est vraiment
grosse ont fait un cube métallique et on
me fait une case de bandes dessinées
tridimensionnelle on s'amusait avec
notre mime et on ne fait d d'écart sur
l'écran il question d'apporter un peu de
concret à ce décor loeb et on le fait
interagir avec ces énormes avec ces
éléments là on s'est amusé à créer des
ambiances et décor abstrait où c'est
pour mettre l'accent sur le côté émotif
de certains numéros
on s'est amusé à créer des relations à
travers cette émotion là de faire une
histoire d'amour entre personnages sur
papier et un acrobate qui faisait de
l'acrobatie aux seuls on ne pousse un
peu la logique aussi question toujours
d'apporter du concret où on écrit mes
créatures à l'écran avec lesquels on
interagit c'est et sur l'image bien
notre mime et des sur des patins à
roulettes
parce que le monde classe le monstre la
siffler d'un côté à l'eau de la seine
elle devait suivre le souffle dessinée
éventuellement on a eu envie d'aller un
peu plus loin on s'est dit
pour être plaisant que le mouvement des
artistes de cirque puissent se retrouver
à l'écran qu'on puisse interagir dans ce
geste là alors l'an 2000 et capteurs des
capteurs des caméras différentes
appareils numériques et on a fait
dessiner nos artistes de cirque à
l'écran éventuellement on était petit à
petit coup un peu plus en avant et on a
commencé à mettre ce qu'on appelle des
capteurs qui naissent aussi des capteurs
de profondeur donc on fait une espèce de
modélisation 3d lui dit mentaires
pourrait dire comme ça alors on ne me
les corps à l'écran on ne donne aux
dessinateurs
allez-y dessinée amusez-vous dans cet
espace
donc vous comprenez que pour nous c'est
un projet extrêmement stimulant et
abandonné au fil des explorations s'est
demandé pourquoi c'était aussi stimulant
ce qui est ressorti c'est
essentiellement que les deux disciplines
qu'on avait mis en contact avait décidé
de ne pas se servir elle même mais de
servir l'autre
le cirque s'étaient mis au service du
dessin le dessin au service du cirque y
avait aucune des deux disciplines qui
était la petite main de l'autre en
rapports égalitaires qui permettait une
réelle communication aurait les changes
entre les deux disciplines
une réelle écoute également et sans
cette écoute là je crois pas que ce
projet leur a été aussi loin qu'on a
réussi à l'amener à ce jour évidemment
on sort un peu parfois du performatif
aussi on va aller notamment du côté de
l'exposition
notre plus récente en 2018 ça a été les
chroniques de montcalm donc une
exposition en réalité augmentée qu'on a
fait dans l'espace public sur l'avenue
cartier à québec pour celle là on est
retourné un peu à nos devoirs
on est retourné vers le médium vers la
réflexion sur le médium bande dessinée
en bd quand on aime bien commencé à
réfléchir sur le médium généralement on
va chez scott mccloud qui est un auteur
qui aussi beaucoup pensé à la structure
de la bd c'est quoi les règles et
comment les éclaté dans un petit livre
qui s'appelle we have band in comics y
amène un principe qui s'appelle dit elle
fait naître canvas
j'explique on ne parlait des planches
tantôt la planche plaisir c'est la page
dans le livre
donc si je crée une bd dans un livre je
veux faire des planches et lui s'est dit
mais si je crée une bd ailleurs est ce
que j'ai encore des planches l'exemple
qu'il a utilisée était la page web en
une page mais les règles la page web et
les règles du livre sont pas du tout les
mêmes
on en convient alors dans la page web
ont pu aller à l'infini en haut en bas à
gauche à droite et donc ce qui fait que
plutôt d'être limité dans une minuscule
âge et bien on peut aller n'est fini un
peu partout on veut créer une histoire
qui va être essentiellement des
annulations et donc dans ce contexte là
eh bien on a adapté l'esprit de la bande
dessinée à ce nouveau médium de la page
papier à la page web
alors ce qu'on s'est dit à travers tout
ça c'est qu'il fallait comprendre
l'esprit de la bd les sens qu'est ce que
c'est eh ben c'est l'idée de raconter en
séquences avec du dessin et du texte aux
besoins en riz si une histoire et dans
ce que l'on ait fallu 30 cette réalité
là et le mettre dans le contexte de la
réalité augmentée deuxième petit lexique
pour faire de la réalité augmentée
on a besoin d'un marqueur nous notre
parker on ne choisit prendre une planche
de bd faut que ça soit visuel marc caron
de plaine visuel pourquoi passe à côté
alors l'idée c'est qu'à travers ce
visuel il ya une application dans
l'informatique qui vont reconnaître les
éléments et qui va faire émerger quelque
chose
donc il faut nécessairement avoir un
écran donc une tablette tactile un
téléphone intelligent l'écran votre déco
des l'information et va générer de la
réalité augmentée donc faire apparaître
les éléments invisibles qui étaient
cachés derrière l'illustration pour ne
proposer
alors évidemment dans ce contexte là il
fallut se questionner sur notre médium
il fallait définir le marqueur donc on
est un espace qui est limité autour de
la page ça c'est votre terrain de jeu
première contrainte
deuxième contrainte l'application si je
fais une application qui est trop lourde
ces personnes vont vouloir la
télécharger alors j'ai mis un maximum
d'informations que je peux rentrer je
peux pas aller dans un détail trop
excessif
visuel par exemple troisième élément ses
lecteurs si vous c'est moi si je lui
quelque chose avec mon téléphone
intelligent faut pas que j'ai trop de
textes parce que c'est bon je vous
apprends rien non plus alors il fallait
aller chercher quelque chose qui était
limité au niveau contenu est ce qui fait
qu'en connaissant donc les contraintes
de notre nouveau médium la réalité
augmentée on ne peut adapter les règles
de la bande dessinée adaptée l'esprit de
la bande dessinée dans ce nouveau cadre
là alors on s'est orienté notre côté
vers une bande dessinée au caractère
familial
on était dans l'espace public avec un
dessin qui était simple du noir et blanc
qui rappelle aussi l'esthétique de bd
qui crée une distance entre la réalité
dans laquelle on propose la bd sur des
murs de briques dans des rues dans
l'espace urbain
on a créé des histoires qui était très
quotidienne très proche des gens très
proches de l'endroit où ils se trouvent
quand il découvre la bande dessinée est
évidemment tout ça nous a pas empêché
non plus de s'amuser à tester les
limites un peu du cadre qu'on s'était
donné d'essayer de voir jusqu'à quelle
hauteur
on pouvait monter jusqu'à quelle
distance on pouvait s'éloigner de notre
marque heures c'est un peu l'heure où
est rendue parenthèses le factuel donc
cinq années de réflexion de travail
collectif et collaboratif pour essayer
de voir comment on peut contribuer on
comptait d'une multitude d'autres
personnes à faire éclater le médium
qu'est la bande dessinée jeudi on n'est
pas seul à faire tout ça est à la limite
je pense qu'on peut contribuer aux côtés
tout ces gens là a décomplexé une
pratique une dizaine d'années le
descendant direct il était cantonné aux
événements bd
ici comme ailleurs est de plus en plus
les auteurs comme les organisateurs
d'événements les programmateurs et les
autres découvrent le potentiel réel de
cette approche là de ces disciplines
moins de moins en moins gêné à
l'intégrer à la proposer à l'incorporer
à leurs activités
autant que pour les auteurs on va voir
aussi une conscience de plus en plus
aiguisée que c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut faire qu'on peut proposer et qui
représentent un intérêt réel et tangible
et ce évidemment on est fier du côté
parenthèse note d'avoir pu contribuer à
ce mouvement leur ici au québec
également par le biais de l'impôt bd
également par le biais de la multitude
d'autres activités qu'on a proposé la
suite pour parenthèse 9
eh ben c'est prendre les trois éléments
qu'on a déterminés au fil des années et
la multitude d'autres de savoir que
notre destin il faut dépasser gadget il
faut le justifier de comprendre qu'ils
font réellement aborder les éléments
dans un esprit de communion et d' écoute
mutuelle et le respect mutuel entre
pratiques qu'on veut mettre en contact
qui faut préserver l'esprit de la bande
dessinée et l'adapter au nouveau
contexte on le propose donc on essaie
règles de base là et pour nous on vous
souhaiter évidemment continuer à les
explorer et voir jusqu'où on peut les
pousser et voir si le septième dans la
durée et dans des projets de plus en
plus impose
merci
[Applaudissements]